[MUSIC PLAYING]
WAYNE PIEKARSKI:
Are you a developer
who's interested in supporting
different languages, locales,
and regions with the
Google Assistant?
I'm Wayne Piekarski,
and in this video,
I'm going to show you how easy
it is to take your existing
apps for the Google
Assistant and extend them
to work all around the world.
The Google Assistant is
available on all kinds
of devices, such as
voice-activated speakers,
phones, and more.
And Actions on Google
is our platform
that allows developers to create
their own apps for the Google
Assistant.
And we're rolling out
new languages and locales
for Actions on
Google all the time.
So whether you want
to say hello, bonjour,
guten Tag, and many others,
we've got you covered.
So let's get started with
explaining a few concepts.
The first thing you need to
know is the concept of a locale.
And this is a string
that represents
the regional
language information
and can be configured by
the user in their Assistant
settings.
As you can see,
there are two parts--
the language, like
EN for English,
and then the variation
of it after the hyphen.
In this case, you can see
there is United States, Great
Britain, Canada, and Australia
as variations of English.
While people in these
regions all speak English,
they have different
words and spellings
for some concepts-- and
even different accents.
For example, the word color
is spelled differently.
And remember, when
someone's using a phone,
the user will read the
text off the screen,
so spelling is very important.
Other things that
can be different
are the ordering of dates
and local currencies used
for payments.
Words can be different, too.
So to say hello, you could
use different phrases like
g'day, or cheerio for goodbye.
The next thing to be aware of
is user location targeting.
This lets you control
the availability
of your app in a specific
part of the world.
And this is determined by
the user's physical location
and not by a locale.
In general, you
should make your app
available to as many locations
as possible, unless it
requires the user
to be physically
present in a specific area--
for example, to
purchase physical items.
So how do we go about using
all these features in your app?
While you could possibly
implement each locale
as a separate app,
most developers
would want to support all
of them within a single app
to maintain only one code base--
keeping common user ratings and
user account linking settings.
We'll show you how to
do this with Dialogflow,
formerly known as Api.ai--
a tool that makes it really easy
to develop conversational apps
for the Google Assistant.
Dialogflow now implements
the ability to specify user
says phrases and responses from
multiple languages and locales.
You click on the plus icon under
Dialogflow Agent Settings gear
icon, and a Languages
tab appears.
Next, you pick from
the list of languages.
Note that Dialogflow is
separate from Actions on Google,
and so it might support
extra languages that
are not available with the apps
for the Google Assistant yet.
Once you have
selected a language,
you can also add
specific locales.
Here's a list of
English locales.
If you don't specify a
locale, then by default,
Dialogflow will apply all of
the locales within a language.
In general, you
should keep things
as generic as possible to
avoid duplication, and only
add specific locales
if you need to make
variations in your dialog.
Now, you can create your
intents like you would normally
do for each language
and locale, but now you
can toggle between the language
chips to specify each one.
If your conversation
is completely
contained within Dialogflow,
then you're done.
But if you're using a WebHook
to generate responses,
you can add locale
support here, too.
The same WebHook URL is used
for all languages and locales,
but you vary the output
in your WebHook code.
If you're using our
JavaScript client library,
we have a method--
getUserLocale-- which can be
used to return the locale.
And you can then use this to
return appropriate strings back
to the user.
For example, you can easily
make different calls to app.ask
depending on locale--
like this-- with a
set of if statements.
And alternatively, there are
JavaScript libraries available
where you define all your
strings in resource files
and then reference them
using labels in your code.
The nice part about this is you
can get translators to convert
these files to many
languages without having
to touch your source code.
This is pretty standard
practice and similar to what
Android developers do with
resource files right now.
Once you've changed
your app, you
need to declare the new
locales to the Google Assistant
in the Actions console.
You can specify different
names and information
about your app for each locale.
By default, the Assistant will
provide a text-to-speech voice
that has an accent based
on the user's locale.
You can also override
that behavior
if you really want to
have a specific accent--
such as of your own persona--
no matter what the
user has selected.
You can also use
the Actions console
to specify location targeting.
As I mentioned
earlier, you might
want to geographically
restrict your app
to only work in certain
regions of the world.
This is based on the
physical location
and is independent
of the language used.
So you can restrict
your action to work
only in Europe, but in
English, French, and German.
Every time Actions on Google
launches a new language,
you can add a translation
in your implementation,
tweak the Actions
Console settings,
and then you're ready
for the review process.
To test your new
multi-lingual app,
you can use a simulator to test
all the possible combinations.
You can specify the surface
to select what kind of device,
you can specify a
physical location
to indicate where
you're located,
and you can also pick
the language and locale.
Now you can try everything out
to make sure your app works
the way that you want.
And once you're
done testing, you
can now use the Actions console
to submit your app for review.
It's really easy to do,
and you'll get feedback
if there are any problems
that your submission doesn't
meet the guidelines.
Once approved, users
all around the world
will have access to your app.
We're constantly adding
new languages to the Google
Assistant, so make sure
your app is architected
to be able to add new languages
easily using the steps I
just outlined.
Many of the Actions
on Google Samples
support internationalization.
Through the Samples, you can
see a working implementation
of our best practices
for internationalization
and understand how to best
use third-party JavaScript
libraries to support this.
To get more
information, check out
the internationalization
documentation
on our developer site.
And finally, we have a great
Actions on Google developer
community on Google+
and Stack Overflow,
so you can discuss ideas and
ask questions about localizing
your app any time.
We look forward to
seeing what you build.
And until next time, goodbye,
au revoir, auf wiedersehen.
[MUSIC PLAYING]